[Music]
[Applause]
these witch hunts shall not stand
says edward scissorhands
it's true captain jack sparrow thinks
cancer culture is
harrowing a new interview actor johnny
depp slammed canceled culture saying
quote it's so far out of hand now that i
can promise you that no one is safe
cause he's not safe not one of you no
one out that door it takes one sentence
and there's no more ground the carpet
has been pulled it's not just me that
this has happened to it's happened to a
lot of people depp of course was
referring to his public legal battle
with his ex amber hurd in which they
both accuse each other of domestic
violence the count basically ruled in
favor court actually by tossing
deb's libel suit i made no sense and i
don't care so is cancelled culture as
bad for johnny depp as it is for any
ordinary slep he has piles of money for
lawyers and influential friends to
support him and although he lost a few
acting gigs he still has his castle
perhaps if he broadened his concern
about this how this hard left
mccarthyism to include the victims who
aren't weirdos who own chocolate
factories
then we'd feel bad for him but it's like
tom jefferson used to say greg you have
amazing calves
tom's my personal trainer
truly julie julie um is this really
cancelled culture or is this it's weird
celebrities showing up late to the party
are welcome to join
but is this because they really see the
problem or that they were finally
targeted i mean okay so if a judge rules
that there's evidence that proves that
you are a violent man and you're a
terrible husband i say fine maybe a
little therapy i'm pretty forgiving i
used to have a major crush on this guy
so like i have to say uh up until he
started the like thick black smudgy line
under his under eye lash line i i i have
a hard time believing that he was that
awful evil person but i still believe in
forgiving i do not believe in cancer
culture and i say get some therapy get
some makeup remover and maybe you can
start a new career
this what do you think what happened to
him no it's not cancelled culture he
sued the sun which i happen to write for
very fine british tabloid newspaper the
son said that he had um
the the son said that he had uh had been
beating his wife
he sued the son he lost
uh that is not cancer culture that is
stupidly bringing a libel action in the
british courts for something that was
true that's totally different from
cancer culture
one of the things that johnny depp is a
lovely actor and i mean you know i i
agree i don't think everybody's life
should just be destroyed even for
something like this but you know the one
lesson from johnny depp is you never sue
for libel uh um
we learned all sorts of things in court
about both him and amber heard or amber
turd as he called how it turned out
because
it turned out that both of them accused
the other of defecating in the bed right
in britain we go to the bathroom and we
think this was very strange behavior
and it's just
we're funny like they were very proper
yeah
and so that went down badly and um and
and you know literally they they ended
up airing their dirty linen in public
literally yes
cat i'm so excited it's the d blocker we
finally got something about poop mm-hmm
i know you were about ready to die yes
exactly what are your thoughts
yeah uh
well look he's right
that it's wrong that you can have you
know be completely canceled over a
single sentence
and it just outweighs the entire rest of
your life and everything about you the
same time i do have a tough time feeling
bad for someone whose scarf collection
is worth more than my entire life that
is true
that is true i think i mean if he joins
the if he joins the anti-cancer culture
war that's great so i welcome him with
open arms i mean look at the border you
have now the progressives that are
saying they're mad at joe biden yeah so
when that happens you know there's a
problem when you have liberals in
hollywood that are saying speaking out
against cancelled culture you know maybe
this is not the right thing to do look
this is america you don't want to watch
fox you don't watch another channel you
can change the channel you have a choice
and we can do that i don't agree with
these boycotts and look i'm glad some of
these celebrities are speaking out
against against kansas culture something
we've been feeling for a long time and
about the celebrity thing we are zealous
celebrities probably right i mean these
guys are asian
do you think you are all right
you i was you didn't let me you
activated him you didn't let me finish
okay you are the a-lister at fox
if you look at the ratings compared to
the other late night shows
you are the a-list celebrity so greg if
i read anything in the tabloids i know
as a z-list celebrity i know
anything they write is probably not true
you are absolutely right thank you so
much for that and she is right brilliant
ainsley earhart hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else